ROGERIO PANIZZUTTI: Our
business at Neuroforma
is to develop and sell
and distribute solutions
to improve your brand.
Two experiments right
now with these products.
One is with patients
with schizophrenia.
Schizophrenia is a very
debilitating disorder,
where people hear voices.
People get stressed.
But also they have
problems in memory,
in attention, the capacity
to solve problems.
And the problem to solve
problems, these impairments
in memory and attention this
makes them very incapable
to do work or social life or
they have difficulties even
to see how people are feeling.
So we are providing this
kind of exercise for them
in the hospital in this
Institute of Psychiatry
here in Rio.
And they are being
evaluated before and after
the intervention
for how they have
their memory, their attention,
and so on works, but also
for their quality of life, how
they are seeing their life,
how they feel about their lives.
And we do this before
and after the training
to see the impact
of the training.
For me, as a
neuroscientist, it is a way
to put neuroscience
to work for people.
And using technology allows
us to reach many, many people
with only a few resources.
In Brazil, as we
are a huge country,
I think that using technology
like that, based on web,
we can use these from Rio de
Janeiro up to the Amazon Forest
or the south of Brazil.
So I think that the
potential for that,
when you think about health,
improving health promotion,
it's huge.
And you don't have so
many things nowadays
to improve mental health,
to promote mental health.